bonjour je m'appelle Nicolas fauvrez je
réside à Sainte-Clotilde je cherche du
travail dans l'infographie sans
multimédia ou dans l'audiovisuel c'est
d'abord mon cursus scolaire j'ai fait un
baccalauréat STI2D donc sciences
technologique de l'industrie option
Itech donc innovation technologique
éco-conception dans le présent je suis
une formation d'infographie en
multimédia pendant mon cursus scolaire
donc chaque temps libre je me consacrer
au graphiste donc pour montage photo
comme montage vidéo
je vais passer par le montant à
motoformer donc avec des tutoriels sur
internet j'ai plusieurs compétences avec
des logiciels tels que Photoshop
After Effects Vegas Pro donc ça c'est
logiciel Image et Vidéo et du côté
infographié sans multimédia donc tout ce
qui touche le web design c'est le
sublime texte Dream Weaver notamment je
suis prêt à aller partout donc c'est à
dire dans mon département donc à la
comme hors départements en France à
l'étranger je suis quelqu'un qui est
très calme organisé je signe créativité
une façon d'imaginer de l'imagination
surtout je suis jeune je n'ai que 18 ans
je suis quelqu'un de très motivé
dynamique et c'est pas parce que on a 18
ans on vient de sortir du cas scolaire
que on peut pas tout de suite intégrer
par manque de
d'expérience dans la vie active donc
dans la vie d'entreprise je m'adapte à
tout ça toutes sortes de missions qu'on
pourra m'apporter